oh no sorry
gym fails we've all done them i haven't
i don't go to the gym
let's look at other people [ __ ] up at
the gym i'm actually very very very
excited whoa
hell yeah caught this dude doing some
sort of carb hip thrust
when i was three sets of 20.
hell yeah hell yeah
the i wish i saw the video
beastiality juice i don't think that
means what you think it means
let me slurp on that [ __ ] oh yeah the
beastiality dude
oh i'm a beast now right
yeah yeah oh
hell yeah gotta get those neck muscles
yeah looking at this perfectly ripped
dude
oh where's his neck muscles though huh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i bet you don't do this huh you can bait
a [ __ ]
oh nice please return weights
hey if you're strong enough to put them
out you're strong enough to place them
in
i tried a new pr in clean
i want pain i want more pain he's back
oh that's next level rowing hell yeah
working out his entire body he's not
working out his neck though
what's the point
this is me at the gym hell yeah
was that the gym for hours i did the
i did the thing what this is doing his
arms are too short
oh my god oh
hell yeah hell yeah more of that please
hell yeah full range you got it man
yeah this is i like this is why people
are afraid of going into the gym because
they're
they're they don't know what they're
doing and they're worried someone's
gonna film them
but what the [ __ ] is that dude this is
just blatantly
hey i i can i can lift that weight sure
look at it
yeah you did it new new record did it
the [ __ ] are they doing nice
if they should kiss between reps it's so
cute
if we lift together we can lift more i
guess shoulders
hell yeah hell yeah you go graves
jerk that thing yeah i don't know if i
feel
bad or if it's
it's still funny i i feel bad but it's
still funny
you know he's an elder guy he's still at
the gym i respect it but
he has amazing form i i got pure respect
yeah
that this is me if i went to the gym i
don't want to make other people feel bad
basically
the mind is the only thing stopping you
hell yeah what even is this
carousel what is that machine
i don't even know how you're supposed to
use that get those triceps
is it supposed to help you to do i'm i'm
so confused what is this machine
[Laughter]
oh okay all right i don't know what the
[ __ ] is doing
but either way don't do more weights
than you can handle
because you just look so [ __ ] stupid
hey girl you don't need to go to the gym
to do that
sign up for 20 20 pound a month gym
membership oh what the
[ __ ] is this jim hell yeah
hell yeah now that's multitasking that
it's fun
crocheting
you know if she did the full motion i
mean at least fine why not but that's
just
you're just wiggling dude and then again
i mean
it's her workout do what she wants i
guess
but what's the point is the other
question
this is such a strange phenomenon why
does it keep happening
like i get it you don't have ever not
everyone have to go in the gym with
their bestiality juice
and just go ripping through every every
wave but what
game god hell yeah hell yeah
stop it get some help
how is it all the same jim what is this
franchise
yeah yeah
you're gonna hurt your back oh oh oh
oh yes
look how look how heavy i left look how
strong i am
like i strongly okay i can lift so much
what is he doing
[Laughter]
hell yeah hell yeah that's respect
that's respect yeah oh
between each rap that's what i'm talking
about
that's how it's done
[Applause]
what a [ __ ] legend how is this the
same gym i want to go to this gym
so bad
i like that the resistance upwards but
he or she does it sideways
all right
honestly i don't even know what's wrong
with this i've never seen this machine
oh he's sitting at the bottom i got it
okay oh my god i see it now it's
supposed to be for
uh crunches or whatever it's called it's
for abs but he's using his arms
see this is why it's a good idea that if
you're new to a gym
just ask sorry i don't really know how
to use this machine could you show me
literally anyone will show you not even
people working there will show you
trust me
best gym on the planet it's a circus i
love it
oh hell yeah you don't know about those
the wall thrust what muscle are you
working out there
i know some exercises look silly but
wait a minute
hell yeah thing is you don't even need
to stand against the wall to do
if you wanted oh man
this is so good must be january again
i'm gonna go fit this time it'll be
different
ah come on come on
nah nah you gotta respect that when
you're in that flow
it don't matter if you look silly
come on come on
oh hell yeah oh [ __ ] yeah that's how
he's done
america america this is just america
i've been to gym many times in america
and it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing
every time
holy [ __ ] it is so bizarre compared to
uk
uk normal gym everything's normal go to
america it just spit
it's so weird everything is weird in the
gym in america
even the normal people are weird i'm not
the least bit surprised
my favorite part is people that are
they're muscular as hell like they have
giant arms but their bellies are like
[ __ ] huge just like you want the
gains you don't want to give up the
cheeseburgers
i respect it in a way but hell yeah
yeah sunglasses in the gym
it's you're not sitting on the bed oh
this is a kid though
come on it's just a kid kids
don't know what you're doing i cannot
say this enough times clearly
[Laughter]
okay oh he's sitting on the thing
no what are you doing no
oh gotta get those neck muscles hell
yeah
i mean honestly neck is kind of those
muscles that's easy to forget about
and you will look dumb as no matter what
right i don't know how you work out your
neck
do i have a thick neck no i don't look
at me look at this [ __ ] as
neck i'm doing neck exercises every day
from now on
i love this
they just don't care it's amazing in a
way
that looks fun to be fair that look it's
all the same [ __ ] gym
this is the most normy gym of all time
like what is it
they have a ton of equipment it's bigger
than the gym i used to go to
good form yes it's the legs that you
work at
during that exercise you got it it's
also like
dude there's a youtube video for
everything now
anything you need to know about exercise
is on youtube
there's so many great fitness youtubers
there's so many great tutorials
instructions that will tell you what
muscles you're working out
what movement you should not be doing
this
hell yeah hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah i feel like i've seen so many
like this
but it's more strength because i have
what is it called like it's not just
about the weight please
listen i know i'm not super buff oh i
don't have the greatest authority but i
think you're
better off with some lighter weights
just do the full range
instead then whatever the [ __ ] this is
plus
if you [ __ ] around with more weight than
you can have you're way easier to get
damaged and hurt
and you'll be out of the gym for a long
time there's no point
i just stumbled on goal here ain't no
game
hey full range you got it nailed it
but i can lift more look how much you
bench bro
just so you can say it right how much
you bench i bench
5000 full range
there bro
stop this same thing again
yeah we got a growler
that was it oh hell yeah hell yeah
i was edited hell yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'm starting to remember why i don't go
to gyms anymore
it's so much more comfortable for me
home it's also i get recognizer and
workout and i hate that
someone someone will film me at the gym
and i'll basically be doing this
i don't even know what that machine is i
have no clue clearly neither does he
i'm curious what people get these ideas
from it's like all right so i'm gonna go
my exercise i'm gonna do my
my routine right this is what i'm gonna
do
where did that idea come from maybe it
has a specific purpose for
his sport or something i don't know but
it's just
interesting get that those neck muscles
choke me like you choked me when you
choked me i only got dumbbells how do i
work out my neck
first with your legs don't bend at your
back just like shoulders bring them down
that helps your neck i do these rotate
the sink
and down up in the front back and down
then we can switch direction up in the
back down in the front
yes that happens in your neck yes and
five to the front
honestly it's the last one on my workout
and i i don't do them that well
this is actually helpful look at that
down in the front
an alternating succession five to the
front five to the back and repeat until
you get a total of 20
do three sets of that and that way
you'll be strengthening your neck and
your shoulder muscle
okay cool awesome always read the
comments and then like and dislike to
make sure it's a good video
all sources i've read says rolling may
cause injury see that
it's so hard to know as well what's
right and wrong i didn't think you were
you were supposed to roll get it
let's go oh [ __ ] yeah
what even is that is that a bicep curl
what is that
this is why i don't do machines wha what
is the benefit
free weights activate more muscles and
machine therefore are better for
building
muscles in the long run however towards
the end of your session when your
muscles are tired and your form is
starting to suffer machines are safer
okay that makes sense and they can help
you train weaker muscles more safely
that's true
what i guess i mean
that's one way to do sorry i don't know
all the names in english
oh sit-ups that's what it's called oh
yeah
get those let's go fast as you can
that's how you do it oh every exercise
needs to be done as fast as possible
this is fascinating oh
hell yeah
what is that machine isn't that for
those
uh to help you in case you can't do it
oh [ __ ] yeah
dude i gotta see some crossfit fails
right
strong
i never tried crossfit but it looks like
an easy way to
get hurt all right i'll save the
crossfit from another time maybe
oh hell yeah oh
to get in the thing
i broke my back you're supposed to use
your arms bro
what the [ __ ] are you doing some
relationship
[Laughter]
some weird stage performance that was
beautiful
absolutely gorgeous i loved every second
that was epic gym fails from the same
gym what is this franchise can someone
from america
in line at me i'm losing muscle masters
watching this
oh it's ten dollars a month well that
explains
it there you have it okay all right
look at graph and i see you guys
tomorrow rofas
looking for some high level gaming gear
check out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at
but you need to be at least six eight to
order which i am of course
you have before december 11th to place
your order
and solidify your place in the gaming
history books
so what are you waiting for buff up your
wardrobe today and head over to base.gg
beso i'm 68 i swear
can i order